okay so we're trying something a little
different here because by god we didn't
go on long enough with the Disney
Afternoon
now we're gonna be coming on longer and
now we're gonna do kind of like a whole
filmmakers film why I mean that not is
whole thing just are the stuff we talked
about which sadly is mostly the bad
stuff but this guy's one of life's ed
ironies that we review crap because but
we don't talk about some F so much
respect for the legend the awesome the
great Don Bluth ya know it's one autumn
word and I'm not be I'm not being
cynical I mean I said it like a jackass
but it it's honestly true right knowing
I got mad respect for them why LA I know
if I want to say the master but one of V
master he was Disney when Disney was not
Disney yeah yeah he got further than
Disney did on some points uh you know
Seifer of NIMH is still every time I see
it it blows me away how good it is uh
then I'll light up that did he had this
kind of trifecta of Awesome and it was
three films in a row and it was um
secret of NIMH Land Before Time in an
American tale yeah and those three film
like if you just fell love all dogs go
to heaven was somewhere in there that
was in between um or not was it I okay I
have no problem with all dogs gonna have
I think it's perfectly fine film oh yeah
in my opinion it down goes through it
yeah it doesn't right but that those
three to me are just so pitch perfect
then all dogs go to heaven is good but
that to think I'm like oh it's good it's
like a good Pixar movie it's like that
was good that is better than almost
anything else out there but like the
other three are like the toy stories
there's something going so perfect um I
think you know when I think of like in
and like I think this is we need to
remind people this in what was an
animation Dark Age yeah like the 80s for
animation well is your Disney for Disney
yeah not not into it what's dead
practically um they were here Bears
movie beat Black Cauldron that's think
about that as me was um the only
interesting thing Disney was doing at
the time was live-action and I actually
like a lot yeah
creepy shit oh but when it came to the
animation it's like I didn't gotta but
okay very much but ugh it's fun you know
uh Oliver and company it's fun Black
Cauldron black alternates it's fine um
but nothing really sticks out like I had
yeah I heard your Great Mouse Detective
is better than both those do a lot
better yeah no I think we spotted a
Great Mouse Detective it's fine but I
never remembered is like oh yeah this is
like ranks among there is the great as
yes because it's not a very - it's not
Land Before Time
yeah that's rhythm in uh you know those
films are I would argue it's like they
capture that Disney feel it but it it
feels like something extra - there's
almost just it is darker and grittier it
maybe not just the grittiness it's
mystical
there's a mystical element to all three
of those movies Land Before Time and NIM
might argue in particular though it's
also there and um I an American tale I
argue that - yeah it's there in American
tale there's a mystical quality but
there so go when you're dealing with
dinosaurs and the magical elements and
NIM that like there is a strange
undercurrent of like I don't know what
do you want call magical realism or
surrealism I orb I would argue that
americantale
as well because even though we care
about the mouse of Minsk is quite no no
but here's the thing even though you
know America we live in America and
stuff like that the way they showed it
it felt like a brand-new world orig you
feel like you're on an alien planet yeah
and you're smelling like this little
waves called a logical world which means
that and that's everything I like about
his movies you see it you see it
generally nimza nod went out but those
first three they're always through kind
of kids eyes and it always means that
the cute things and the sweet things and
the joyous things are always played up
so much but sword the scary things yeah
like there are moments in those films
that are terrifying as fuck well I've
even secret name I mean she is not used
to being in these environments I am
either playing innocent to the story
Alice probably stays home you know with
the kids a lot of them as a political
yeah I mean but all the more I mean all
those stories really play into that
these are characters that are not used
to these big grand worlds are both grand
wonderful and grand terrifying and you
guide you appreciate the in American
tale when he finally finds that family
activate macaque teaching us the whole
film oh and it's so painful because
they're always this close
Oh as a child no like literally me also
so mean but it's so brilliant 1980s when
this film came out we were like all of
us little kids are in the cinema in life
like if you can imagine the screen
talking was so pay but it's beautiful
because when they do get together and
the music plays and the animation goes
golden and it's all shining and
sparkling and they're honking in the
James Horner music just like fuckin ah
it's just one of those things where it's
like you never felt more happy in your
again perfect ending with the copper
Statue of Liberty the Sun rising and
what is it what that is mom Anika I
don't like it just and setting up for a
crappy sequel that we would do not want
to talk about but even ah it's not
matters it's not good ah bullshit but
you know but even even the ending is
like you have this whole film where
you're teasing does it even when they're
they're always being closer and closer
and finally they're looking at it's to
the point where the boy doesn't even
like he hears the violin it's like oh
it's just another trick you know no he's
there it's there and then he hears I'm
calling a Paw Paw Paw Paw you see him
running it but even then like they run
fancy chairs I could no no don't go back
go back they turn around they run past
each other again no no don't go back ok
and they are building up this
unbelievably touching heart they give a
child a heart attack that's what
watching that movie was like likely
seriously it's like on the one hand is
it like as a kid I haven't like fuck you
in a balloon I can't take it
take it but like as an adult and even
after seeing the movie as a kid you just
realize how good it is
and it sticks with you because of that
yeah like those three movies stuck with
me more than anything else
I saw animation wise as a kid um because
of that you might you might be right
what other Disney films came out of the
80s and you're like yeah that stuck with
you more than those three movies I had
to think we're probably all I don't talk
about Disney just anime films in general
if I bite you yeah it might be right now
I mean okay there's some Disney films we
saw on TV like you know there's but I
usually know know by me like at that
touch me the baby and wholefoods mother
buys it like it oh maybe this is the
time to that I mean baby not you too but
I cut away pretty quick I mean this oh
god another great scene Land Before Time
I love where in that dinosaur was that's
narrating the story somehow knows what
happens but he only shows up for that
brief scene where he started a little
foot after the mother dies and again if
like if you could give a voice actor and
Oscar that guy whoever did that voice
just though it's a knock come on you're
not a boy sad being is that whole movie
is amazing that's no good there are some
of it rock with tragedy I might add oh
yeah um but I I always felt particularly
in the blue films versus some of the
Disney ones when you get more than one
kid character together in a Disney movie
something always feels slightly off to
me like it's very much Disney's
interpretation of how kids act
I always felt those early blue films
they felt like kids
yeah like when when Sarah fights would
look like it's yeah that is just a
smackdown and like I'm like that's how
kids funny like I remember fights like
that
well I remember to like where it's just
like you can think of the cruelest thing
you could say he's one to smack this
shit like kids can be mean a little
bastard ya know and when they actually
were done fighting I think Sarah like
you know beats him up or something like
that he's just there he's double black
guy you just a little like sniffing the
blond detail
yeah like what a great detail
he's got a very remember that almost
like psychic pressing kind of Miyazaki
and sense for detail in picking the
right moment just to highlight to make
it ultra realistic because Miyazaki
would always do that there's always the
one twitch of the face or like the hair
standing on end or some little detail
you're like wow like other directors
would have missed that and bluth always
gets well with americantale - I mean if
iPhone let's be honest is not like the
smartest most interesting character but
you really do feel like this kid's got
to be like you know what fine or
something yeah watch and act like an
annoying five-year-old but you get it
he's he's still this charming little
innocent and he's so light I think
George Reeves should have taken note
yeah he did and again you watch this
movie he can be annoying but it you felt
real yeah and feel fake by it cuz it
feels real and you know is you're
probably good for that you don't seem in
a podrace then you be like it feels way
more real than that mm-hmm like not as a
construct but so those early but it oh
and the other thing about him that I
always loved um I always feel it's worth
mentioning because consider all the
Disney movies where you're lucky if a a
parent survives the movie and be any
longer here yeah you're lucky if your
parent survives beat you're lucky if
there's a parent at all and see you're
lucky if they have parent particularly
if it's a male character isn't some
fucking more like those are the three
Disney parent tropes well and it's
always the mothers secret of NIMH I know
it's based on the book but the balls to
take a story particularly that far back
in the early 80s to take a story that
centers around a single mother who is
strong but also vulnerable who you know
is confident you know who's trying to do
something as simple as save her own kid
like compare that to all the other
Disney movies or it's always like I mean
the it should have been the frickin
sequel or it's like well Tim you should
be the star you know and yet that movie
is obviously the inferior one um so to
have the balls I think to like do a
story that has a main character like
that
is amazing and he doesn't flawlessly I
have no idea if he actually said this
quote it might have been somebody else
coined it about Don blue but its unquote
I really believe in uh which is you can
show kids practically anything as long
as there's a happy ending oh it's true
cuz no more with all the good eighties
kids films yeah and you were because you
are building up to a happy ending you
are working for that happy ending and
you're going through a lot to get to
that happy ending
oops films oh but the endings are so
happy and they relish it and they soak
it up I remember when I saw the boobs
films like that so they it's like
something's work for their happy I think
blue spoons is like slave labor yeah
like you're sitting there carrying giant
rocks being whipped horse whipped and
then finally you get the happy ending
but it makes it all the more worth it
you saw the Jim Carrey Christmas Carol
right yeah yeah yeah that's got some
good stuff in but there's it's mostly so
dark but again Christmas Carol parva
it's like you go to the dark to get to
the happy and even the happy is kind of
dark and a little underwhelming either
says if there's not that much an
appreciation of Christmas like there
should be where with the down blue film
when the happy stuff comes it is so
cheerful and so joyful and just
perfectly badly this awesome feels who's
happy because I was very worked it feels
warranted and yeah I think that what the
movie speak very much to an emotion I
mean not quite as much to say something
like Wizard of Oz or something but they
they play very much the emotion and as a
kid I mean I know I was watching this
feeling like I know the good ending is
coming by God going through tough stuff
to get through and I have to survive it
and I got a metaphor this it kind of is
and he really at least emotionally
address away the joyous moments because
you got to work for it and the kids you
know I mean I think emotionally that's
how kids kind of you know that's how
they communicate for a while so that's
how you get through school yeah I mean
anyway you guys howls you can come home
and watch the Disney Afternoon but but
that's how you understand things when
you're kid you understand things
motion that's why something like you
know and wizard of oz' these down blue
films hold up so well because they
understand that emotion they understand
what has to go you know into it and how
to communicate with emotion oh if I
might add gorgeous
gritty 80s animation yeah like I mean
the we wouldn't even be having half of
this conversation if it wasn't so
gorgeous to look at we'd still be going
like oh yeah I mean it's it's a very
emotionally involving film but like the
animation completely complements that
it's not one of those things there's
like oh well the emotions better than
the animation or vice-versa
it's like you know there's some animated
films were like well the brave was
whatever I'm like wow this film is
gorgeous and I can't stand it
yeah um so it's uh but it's definitely
something where I mean I people still
talk about these films I know we I know
we make fun of you know the later down
blue stuff and everything cuz it mrs.
Brisby hanging over yeah Grizz be right
there uh but it's it is one of those
where it's like yes it is easy to make
fun of II even argue as kind of low
blows and stuff um and I I don't know
what happened and you like the films I
see people I like it you know please do
anime films are so tough to make films
in general so tough to make animation is
even tougher because even just waving a
hand is a shit-ton award do you tell an
actor wave a hand and do it fine but
just you have to animate frame-by-frame
doing that and you know hundreds of
people don't have known up here
somewhere and it is not for us to judge
yeah um it is for us to say that no we
don't like these later films as much as
the earlier ones but what exactly have
like I have no idea I mean it could be
anything it could be nobody was giving
him good scripts it could be nobody was
giving him a lot of money it could be
well maybe he was just doing it for a
paycheck cuz you would have to work um
whatever was there is definitely a
significant difference in quality and I
I felt like it started with maybe
rock-a-doodle yeah I think I was the
first that was the first one where I
remember yeah and that was that was my
exact range I remember
they're watching it going what is this
Oh what the heck I'm we're dead what
this is this isn't fun we're like is
really some like all thoughts go to
heaven was weird but it still felt like
no I would have answered and yeah
although it's gonna have some Sun Kai
your ear but good movie it still went to
the dark and the ye - everything and it
felt like again emotionally even though
the plot makes no sense but emotionally
it's still hitting those out all dogs go
to heaven is like the middle one just
because it's like I don't think it's as
good as those original free but I still
think it's a very good movie so I don't
want to throw it into that later
category it's like it still to me
belongs in that earlier booth but but
post all Don's I yeah like and rocketed
was the animation was pretty like it was
well animated I can't complain and say I
just what the hell was that about
yeah I don't know it is not a felon I
have no idea like I said I I feel like
the story it was based on must not have
made much sense to begin with I've
already changed it I don't know I feel
like I don't think this is the case but
it feels like it was commissioned you
know if that makes sense like in a hey
we want a story for Lucas this age range
about you know Santa Clara Chanticleer
story about the rooster crows and breaks
the Sun do something with man except
upgrade a little bit maybe a country
singers go go
and like all over much time all I
remember is the trailer all I can do boo
boo ya know like a brother no
advertising it we go idea how they
advertise this move you watch the
trailers over there yeah you can tell
the ad guys everyone got like three
different kinds of commercials one was
like by day he's a rocking rooster but
by night he's an action hero it's like
if that's not the movie we got next
night he's mad
oh he's cog man and that's the actually
that's a good way of putting because I
feel the later blue films sadly and I
again I don't know what happened I can't
ever know about I get maybe we should
just email him and ask but then again he
knows who we are
oh I just I don't want to be that jerk
like cuz like I would have to preface it
with eight paragraphs about how we love
this earlier ya know I mean it is well
things where it's so tough to talk about
even if it was like there is something
that had changed and I like I don't know
was he just being commissioned
were they not personal projects like
maybe the earlier three work is it why I
mean some of these you had Spielberg yes
feel bro doing a hocus on some of that
but now that isn't yeah I mean he's a
good producer Spielberg's idea yeah
Spielberg's a guy you want in your back
in your corner so maybe that was it
maybe he was getting too much
interference from crappy producers baby
Spielberg was helping maybe there was
just such a synergy between those guys I
don't know but yeah like Baraka
Doolittle started it and I could still
have argued that I was just like well
that's you know everybody has a project
like you know Spielberg at 19 I got a
moment penguin were you with yeah and
then yeah pebble the penguin hill in
Central Park
Charles Central Park Ollie's argue is
obviously for like little it a little
little little little little little
little kids but that's still down blues
man and you you've done stuff a little
little kids and adults as well and it's
liking that doing it's because it's done
blue if it's artisan and the animation
is still so good that like when you see
it not going to this is the Gotham is
like it's like Hitchcock directing
Barney's great adventure it's like sure
it's gonna be a well made movie but
that's such talent going to something
that it's like I'm like you could find
anybody to do
troll in Central Park and then five
bucks and say make me drink like it to
have an animation that good and troll in
Central Park I'm like this story just
doesn't doesn't seem to war into like
talent this good like I maybe that's
part of its like we just know what
talent is it
eat you up inside now there is no I mean
I think we do have to mention then um
Anastasia
yeah and it's anti HIV because we're
only the two best clearly of the later
blue good
oh they're you know actually here's the
thing as you know hey here's the thing
they both this is how you go full circle
because those both felt like Disney
movies I'm like one of the guys well uh
nine is Disney oh come on like when we
had a Atlantis or
Treasure Planet wasn't a lot better they
both that both those movies felt like
and again I'm like what's he just
commissioned to do those is that Fox was
just like listen we want to compete with
Disney well hey Don Bluth like he's a
bit
it's a shame cuz he was coming out at
just the wrong to even Disney didn't
wanna be Disney at that point and you
can tell but there was a law yeah
because there was a long time do it um
you know even if they like you did at
our time they turn out to be hits and
that's why I'm saying like it's just it
was the wrong time to try them but they
they didn't know nobody knew we're all
kind of waiting for next Lion King or
Beauty and the Beast to kind of bring
things back but it never really did and
yeah I got Roseanne Barr as a cow
believing a great never know mother
yeah that was those when everything was
going on that was their troll in Central
Park
oh yeah um but here's the funny thing I
mean again I think tiny and Anastasia
many animations gorgeous Anastasia like
I feel like could have been a good movie
it just was not written what here's my
problem with both phones you got the
cheesy Disney sidekick with Bartok you
got Christopher Lloyd who is completely
wasted like a great voice actor you know
doing raspy I'm like I feel like
somewhere in here there is a great
disney-esque story trying to get out
like I think I wanted to be princess in
the fraud but it just couldn't pull off
and again like I I don't think Bluth
wrote that movie so I think it's no
here's my problem
Dale is like well I don't know but but
here's my problem both those movies time
stasia is that even Bluth and his
fucking craziest gave us something
really weird really bizarre and
distinctly him even though you can't say
okay let's Disney rock-a-doodle yet make
it real like Anastasia is so trying to
be Disney and titania is so trying to be
what's popular at the time with the
sci-fi and the shooting in the action
films and stuff and they'll incorporate
more CG and stuff like that that it felt
so even though the animation weather was
beautiful it felt so phoned in and so
not passionate and like we are just
hitting this which sucks because you can
see the Bluth animation trying to break
out of his crew yes I felt like he was
passionate about rock udall makes no
sense as a bad movie but I by letter i
animated they don't know I'll curse a
let me do what I got fucking it out in
this movie that movie's a fucking acid
trip I mean I give it dad it's like I
don't know if I get this in the least
but it's yeah I'm insane and like in its
own ways at least like you you can take
your eyes off if you're like so fucking
rooster in a mouse we're gonna be
singing like Elvis what the hell is is
in terms of a comprehensive story yes
annotation tiny make more sense but in
terms of like something that's like hey
this is a film that's like I want to see
this again I mean I went objectively
though if you're gonna say what's the
better okay
okay I'll give rock-a-doodle - what the
fuck factor no eventually I'd rather see
again like I would almost choose like
rocket a little over those two films
honestly I station I could you know I
could I could see rock-a-doodle I would
probably still take time a in Anastasia
we're told in Central Park and nomadic
women maybe you got the trouble because
I love watching the I love watching the
animation but an SH especially I'd
rather watch Dragon Slayer or Space Ace
Nelson those are dragons dragons the -
Dragon's Lair games work in the even
space work amazing as their own mini
movie ya know I like what I like what we
got they want to play but minivan plays
I did
no where am I supposed unfuck photos
they awful but I love watching women
came when they came on disc like you
could buy light-years after the laser
disc in the arcades where we blew how
many quarters that's what you did to us
but if we waste so much money on your
dancing you're amazing
uh after blowing all that money like
eventually how he was about eight years
ago they came on disc um he was but
maybe yeah eight or the headlights go
they come a disc yeah and yeah we were
play for a while but eventually like
there's an option where you could just
watch it oh fuck this yeah cuz it's
amazing batshit crazy animation down
Dragon's Lair - especially oh the Alice
in Wonderland house with a banjo and are
just gorgeous yeah they make no sense
but they're gorgeous and there's it's
one of those where it's like Disney
wishes it did that in Fantasia 2000 that
Beethoven level is amazing uh no and
it's one of those things where it's like
I don't know what happened and I've
heard rumors I've had fans tell me that
even he admits to not liking some of the
later ones that made some but I'm not
gonna state that because I'm not gonna
put words into somebody else yeah I
haven't heard it firsthand so but no
it's what he's one of those talents
where it's like no matter what comes he
he could make the shoes come back and be
you know have make this film at me he'll
bring hand-drawn animation banger where
maybe he'll make a film that's the worst
of all of them I don't know but he did
these films that not only played a big
part in childhood emotionally a big part
in childhood but still hold up today and
so many kids are gonna case watching
this hard so many of us in the best of
ways ladies so many children so
wonderfully scarred but really think
about a good thing but that cathartic
like you need to be scared scarred go
through emotion sorta way really thing
it turns a hand-drawn animation
directors even outside a Disney Disney
they sort of switched up the directors
for a while and then they'll team up
with different directors and stuff like
that like and there are some that I
can't know cuz I'm animation guy but
like most people know who Don Bluth is
because he is directed a slew of anime
that they remember and has this distinct
style and has really touched a lot of
people and there's very few animation
directors that can do that maybe they'll
make up film maybe - I mean this guy has
looks like rocket it's like ranking is
beautiful it's like rankin/bass or Ralph
patchy it is so unmistakable himself
like there you see a blue film you can't
mistake it for anyone else unless
they're consciously trying to rip off
down blue I've seen a couple of animated
films are like somebody's trying to do a
Bluth impression here but I say you you
could argue that is it does have a
Disney like a strong Disney influence
over see yes please buddy but I feel
dumb I like it working Michael why don't
just need don't like watch it down blue
that'd be like that's the Don Bluth like
I could still tell with you are they are
you explain American Taylor Land Before
Time are like Spielberg's answer to
Disney but it still needs to move yeah
like you look at and you're just like
I'm sorry it's not a Disney film that's
it's it may be trying to be a Disney
film but it is unmistakeably Don Bluth
and that's why I love Don Bluth yeah as
mother we came here to complain about
his weight of shit and ya know we're
never turned the phrase I'm sorry sound
like me we can just go into da Bluth
movies like the bad ones but maybe we
can sort like seriously pin but what's
tough to talk about is like yeah it's
like there's III like I can't remember I
can't remember to roll in Central Park
I barely remember pebble in the penguin
and honestly I just think that's for the
best I would rather remember good look I
do remember the animation and some of
the songs from Anastasia
um and tiny I don't remember anything is
really bad um I did not hate that movie
anywhere near as much as you did but
yeah but I'd still felt it was very much
in that land of Disney same thing of
like it was alright but he wasn't it I
really didn't like it like I think like
isn't it like I was like oh I don't like
this this doesn't feel like blue thumb
in you're in a bad spot with you're in a
bad spot get out of here get
you this isn't you uh it's a try but um
no it's it's one of those things return
your credit check run no it's actually
don't cash that paycheck we think of
Mexico the hurry before you have to
animate another frame again and I
haven't kept up with the ways to do i I
hear he's been doing more teaching uh I
CLE have not kept up um but he's all
those guys I met you know and raped I
cuz that that water hole plays in please
Idid like your IRA an animations go be
like my teachers don bluth i'd be like
holy shit or maybe does like his own for
something i don't know but his stuff
like i said there are so few hands one
hand on the rails again though i don't
want him to go out with it i i would
kill it one more big like like finale
like final project or it's like even if
not i mean leave enough now we've got
those original three yeah i mean the
stuff he's done is just so impressive
and like i said it i don't think people
realize how hard it is to make a navy
named Naaman hug him it to make it
animation itself is so hard but to make
a name alone as an animation animator
he's gone
yeah i mean to where when you say don
bluth you can not just name a film you
can name like four or five films i'm you
know my animation that is but don't you
just want to see another really great
down blues project um but like I said
but I'm so amazed at what and so happy
with what I've gotten and the impact is
left that you know if it turns out
something happened they could never make
another film or something it's like I'd
still be okay because the stuff I'm the
blood what I mean think about it those
original three wasn't really cuz for
nostalgic just like the two members the
chipmunk movie in a Care Bears head I
mean those original three worthy
eighties like the Great Mouse Detective
was fun honestly I don't you Disney's
best film out errors probably rescuers
down under yeah um but but even that
light when I think of like I don't know
mouth after Little Mermaid remember
that was at Oh someone we want 1991 some
like that okay yeah so you're still
you're looking at Great Mouse Detective
Black Cauldron and what was the other
one was all of our company yeah come on
yeah what a whole others do don't even
like when I think of 80s animation I did
to me those are the footnotes Oliver and
company like I shouldn't say that
they're in the middle the footnotes of
Care Bears movie chipmunk movie but it's
it's all Tom blue 80s animation to me is
Don Bluth and no other yeah and real
like I said it when I saw ISOs on my
Disney sempron of Oliver and company and
then when I saw I want to see Oliver
company more because I'm like wow the
Loki ago it's a cool dog but shady sing
it and never laugh and it's a good shoe
I love them and I want to see leg before
time as well but it's like I really want
see Albert come because I'm the
depression volt idiot kid uh but we
couldn't get tickets and we got tickets
to see Duane before time and we landed a
movie yeah we went over there and I
really liked I said wow that was like as
a little kid I'm like that's what I
thought I was gonna get in a really good
way that was like a really really good
film and then all right let's go see
Albert and company and I felt fucking
gypped honestly and the film Ozzie is
not even that bad of film but after land
before time I'm like oh which one was
fucking Disney you literally get a 7
year old sinner cunt
I felt fine seeing Oliver and company I
felt like before time is a better movie
but no cuz I didn't really good yeah
that's a little kid I mean it's watching
it now so clear that this film would be
better when before time but as a little
kid I was really looking for an alpha
and company and then I just felt so
pissed off that like wait a minute then
you were supposed to be the Disney film
that this is the guy that came from you
he's not about that the key statistic
abuse a lot better than you right now
you are he is much better Disney he's
giving me the Disney I wanted and he
made a darker and he made it more adult
any be even more emotional than what
you're giving right now so you're maybe
we start a petition get Steven Spielberg
involved we've get the old eighties team
leave a kiss out
Hocus out he's he's good he's retired
I'll be like one of those 80s movies
like I know we're getting the group back
together spheal bird Bluth you know what
though now Bubba watch them we'll get
like Kingdom Crystal Skull ah
I know Lucas stuff maybe we'll study
movies was involved with that but our
80s heist movie heist animation movie
getting the band back together man uh
we'll see what we can do but uh ya know
I thought this was supposed to be sort
of like talking you know about the films
we reviewed like the bad ones and stuff
but it's like now I just we'll keep it
very simple rock-a-doodle what the fuck
did I just see it's an acid trip kind of
you know you might find it entertaining
because it's an acid trip pebble the
penguin sucks and troll in Central Park
sucks yeah that's that's all we can say
about it yeah cuz otherwise we're just
like ripping them apart or one of our
heroes so animation in front of no man
it's not right
animation Rocko duels still it still
looks pretty good
peb on the Penguins starting to slip a
little bit you can sort of see like oh
they did crop this rikes don't see the
line stop here the color stop there and
stuff and then like I was going to troll
a central park like thanks man I don't
read the animation like being especially
bad is it just got wasted you know like
my other colors we're still free don't
say visit at least those two films just
kind of sucked holy all together they
just there's and that's why it's hard to
talk about it's just like just every
single thing that could suck just ended
up sort of sucking and there's so much
more good to talk about with Don Bluth
yeah and better to just suck big and
just say there goes it sucks and move on
than to sit here and pick it apart so ya
know I mean if there's anything you see
I we much where talk about the great
things about blue Vista so you haven't
seen those three or I'll go the original
four let's troll dogs good I would rent
them now what's your problem they're
very very good and very likes it very
different they have a Disney feel but
they're still uniquely
their own thing and you want to know
where we came from that's our job is for
movements right there so um yeah that's
about it and we'll see in the next month
later